so is it I just love this because you're
so classy to me and you're like this
amazing actress and you love Real
Housewives I'm obsessed
I wasn't everyone I I I don't I don't
generally watch so what's your favorite
thing about it why I my friends love it
I like to find the characters on it like
when I did a most violent year I binged
watched
um uh The Real Housewives of New Jersey
so all those hand gestures
New Jersey it was there
it was there Centric people right yeah
and then because of the Nate Because by
the nature of being on television it's
all magnified yeah so all these like
really interesting things about them are
so much bigger and and I kind of steal
it for my characters oh my gosh that's
incredible what's your favorite one
there's like a lot of them I love I have
so many favorites but I think of course
Beverly Hills might be the that's your
OG for me and I love garcelle I'm
obsessed with garcelle because she I
mean we all just need a friend like her
she's just so honest all the time and I
love her I love her she doesn't care
about anything all my friends are honest
I could use a liar
all my friends are really honest I was
like I'm just kidding I love that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]